okay so I am with Julie and Emory famous
from Fargo better crossed off I'm
currently on preacher as Laura
Featherstone
I'm so excited as interview she's one of
my favorite characters on the show and
she's with me now Julie how are you
doing today I'm really good that was
such a sweet introduction thank you oh
no problem
question I have for you because it's
such an interesting character you're
playing on creature was when you were
cast as Featherstone what was the
approach as an actress did you say okay
because the show is based on comics did
you jump into reading the comics now
like about the character or do you kind
of just go from the script and not want
to touch that I am a big nerd actor wise
so I immediately jumped it I actually
jumped into the comics during the
audition process because I really wanted
the role badly and there is like a
beating heart a Featherstone is straight
from the comics for me in terms of
building out my backstory and who
Featherstone is but there are added
dimensions to Featherstone for the show
that had to come straight from like
script that was coming in from the
writers and stuff so that's where I get
to is I feel like the difficult part
with the role like Featherstone is you
read some of the comics I don't know if
you finished all the comics with her
halfway through I thought I would like
breeze through them really quickly but I
got really sucked in really fast so I
didn't want to read them quickly so I
kind of I got through where I thought we
would get to this season in the show and
then I started like reading them you
know more for more for pleasure right
I'll say yeah so I'm going through I've
got I've gotten to like the Featherstone
backstory bits in the comics and I'm bet
in terms of I'm about halfway through
okay so that's the thing when you saying
feathers some backstory bits in the
comics when you're playing your
character now on TV how much are you
thinking about where you know the comics
go but wait like is a TV show gonna go
there like are you feel conflicted on
your decisions you make ask whether
stone is an actress I don't feel
conflicted I you know the way I work is
from a character place and that mostly
involves backstory so I have my own
backstory for Featherstone
may or may not come into play on the
show the show could go a different
direction with Featherstone's backstory
but for myself as an actor I've built
that out I always try not to look to the
future because you know preacher
preacher changes things quite a bit
right the the TV show from the comics
the mote mostly because if we went if we
did a frame by frame of the comics we
would already run out of material
because they just moved so quickly but
it's uh I try not to look forward to
where Featherstone is going I try to
deal with like where she has come from
up to this point and then deal with the
material at hand that that is a really
good strategy thing for sure and it's
interesting you say that if they went
straight to the comics yes they be
breezing through way too quick so I
think it's smart how the creators are
handling like taking their steps with it
and still making sure it's a solid show
and a good pace and I think I was asked
about Featherstone when you we're
reading some of the comics when you're
auditioning for the part did you look at
the picture Featherstone Zach oh my god
this is me especially because your
iconic bangs you have and then in the
comics whether stone has these great
bangs like you have did you feel like
I'm born for this well I was not when
they wrote the original version of
feather shown I was not the prototype
like they were going for a much more
sort of margot robbie type they looked
for the role for like three months the
character itself went through a lot of
changes and I think honestly the
character as they as it went through the
character went through changes in the
audition process I think it came closer
to the comics I think they kind of
brought her to more I don't know
Featherstone appropriate place off the
page but I came in very late in the
audition process I I just got I mean it
was either one of those kismet things
where they weren't looking for me
early on in the process and then finally
I came in or I mean it was just meant to
be or where I just got really super
lucky but when I did read the material
when it finally came across my desk I I
went after it really hard I mean it's
one of those great great female roles
right like that's that's something you
lay it all on the line for right
and it was pilot season that's why I was
auditioning for all kinds of like wife
of the funny guy or all kinds of parts
that kind of felt boring to me so to
have something like Featherstone come
pop up on my computer for my agent was
it was just thrilling I has to be
amazing I mean like I feel like yeah
it's always a dream to plan he's sort of
villain especially female villains
nowaday because they can definitely be
the coolest and I think you're playing
it so well now what do you when you got
be your agent contact you about like you
know this possible addition did you know
at first as a Seth Rogen and Evan
Goldberg project from season 1 or were
you like did they just tell you that
today add nerves to the old well I was I
was a fan of season 1 ok I had done a
couple of readings of a play in New York
with Anatole Yusuf who was one of the
angels on season 1 and yeah and so I and
I watch almost everything on AMC anyway
it's very much up my alley I'm a fan
yeah I'm a sci-fi fan I'm a fantasy fan
I it's the show really is right in my
sweet spot so I was a big big fan of
season one already that added to the
pressure for me because I like the show
I've I am a fan of what AMC does in
general so the idea of I don't know
landing on an AMC show full-time was
incredibly appealing to me as an actor
um Sam Catlin comes from the Breaking
Bad writers room that was as much
pressure to me as Seth and Evan but even
though that Evan are amazing but like
you know I'm enough of a nerd about what
we do in the business to go oh my god
that's Sam Palin you know so it was
anything bad actor oh yeah yeah exactly
and and the actors on the show are so
are so very high end there's a very high
level of work happening even though the
show is a comic book series and it goes
to such wacky crazy places there's
always like a grounded wonderful acting
space happening with the with the other
people on set yeah and I was gonna say
with this last episode of creature we
just saw with it really delving into the
Grail and you hair star and finally we
finally got the villain trio together
right we fight
I got that going on and what I love
about that is like you have the good guy
trio
and then you have a villain trio so it's
like an awesome like triangle versus
triangle thing and deeper into that it's
also you got a little love triangle in
both because we see Hoover is kind of
obsessed with either hinting at and
you're obsessed with hair
yeah he's obsessed with strange fetish
porn but yes he's obsessed with power
and his own thing for sure and he
continues I mean he's just so
devastating two photos shown over and
over and over again it's such a
different rent dynamic for her she's so
large and in charge all the time that
then to get into a room with hair star
where he just nothing all the time was a
really beautiful opposite and how
awesome to talking about the show at
large how I continually would read
scripts and feel so lucky that the show
was that willing to add another badass
female character I mean tulip is so
badass and amazing I'm so grateful they
didn't go a different direction with
Featherstone I'm so grateful so that
they allowed another strong capable
woman to be on the show absolutely I
think I think it's awesome I think you
always need that especially the villain
side to is we see a lot of females now
that and the protagonist I but we need
more female domes I feel and it has such
a an edge to the show I think and it's
interesting you say that would through
the negative too late' because I
personally love the humor that fits in
with the growl and you guys as villains
because you guys will be doing some dark
stuff and then you get pop-ups about do
you like cats during that scene with the
drone how do you not break character
when you're like you're seriously doing
this and then there's something like
that but how do you not just start like
laughing on set how does that work I
mean so that's what do you say that
because last night I just approved the
gag reel for the season 2 DVD so we
don't always do that yeah so we don't
always keep it together I'll tell you
what cracks me up more than like if it's
scripted and I know it's coming that I
can prepare myself for but Malcolm
Barrett is just so freaking funny all
the time he doesn't need words to be
funny
he is hilarious and he breaks me a lot
he I could see the light on like our
scenes together just work and they're
fabulous but
he and he continues to play all day so
in every take there's something
different it's really it just breaks me
and Featherstone is so in my scenes with
Hoover feathers shown proper is so just
sort of flat and serious and focused
that it's really hard when Malcolm
breaks me yeah live in her you know
she's just deadpan all the time true and
that's what I think is so good about you
and Malcolm together on this show
because the scenes with ruth negga and
two of coming to the door it's time to
see you next door
I think I'm shaped shift like I usually
do change you should wear disguise and
he just gets on his phone and horns like
a closet I lose it I wrote the funniest
thing that let's some go like comedy a
throw in there and you guys do it great
I was going to say to when we first see
you this season and you're the jazz
singer and you got the blonde wig on
when you get into that process where
that episode was mostly you in disguise
ha like cuz again you have these
notorious bangs where do they go like
I'm confused it's you almost like wow
it's like really flips me off like
that's the same woman how do they do it
if they put your hair back I don't know
hair stuff so I'm just curious yeah so
that Donita Blanche is my hair stylist
and Amy Wood is the is the key hair
stylist on the show and they did a
brilliant job with the wigs I think and
and every character every persona that I
have we do a test process for so I'll go
in on a day I'm not shooting they for
the blonde wig for the jazz singer they
actually do paint a big portion of my
own hair underneath the wig because the
dark was showing through they do some
makeup with it and then we photograph
and we do a little video and send it up
the ladder for approvals and I weigh in
on what I think is right for the
character like the jazz singer was
almost a redhead and it was between that
and the sort of platinum blonde and then
we went through the whole thing again
with Jenny and we get so every time
there's a new persona we do a new test
round almost as if it's a introducing a
new character to the show and to have
that level of you know actually with the
jazz singer the costume designer
requested that I get into the wig and
the makeup and then come put on the
dresses that she wanted to use so that
we could see the full effect for that
introduction so there's a very high
level of commitment behind the scenes to
helping me make those transformations
and then I get to you know internally
make the transformation I really wanted
to make Featherstone a brilliant actress
cuz I think it's just more diabolical
like if she's willing to embody all of
these things and other people that she
sees as sin or that she judges that
that's see that if she's willing to so
fully embody that in order to lay a trap
or to go undercover I just think that
makes her I it just makes her so much
more interesting to me yeah I would
agree with that and I think you have
such an opening here where I think the
most exciting part about Featherstone's
you have endless possibilities of what
you might transform into in one disguise
so I
yes that's like you can don't you super
excited about that as an actor it's a
complete thrill right so I've always
latched on to transformation as an actor
from rolled to roll
RIT led me to Betsey Kettleman on better
call Saul but to have all of that in one
role is you don't even dream that that
could happen you know I mean that's just
amazing I do like when Jenny came up
actually for both Lara and Jenny I send
like little dialect options to the to
Sam Catlin and the writers on like I'm
like here's where I think I'm thinking
of going with her and then they weigh in
and we kind of developed that together I
send like different sort of I don't know
vocal register options and I do little
we do little tests for everything it's
really thrilling and it's so you know
it's so scratches minor ditch as an
actor it's so great but I love that like
from someone in the nerd culture and
under myself obviously the stuff behind
me I think we love seeing actresses and
actors that embrace that nerd side and
that oh they're actually into this
they're not just doing this for a check
and that's what's so cool coming off
about you that you really enjoy it for
what it is in the art of it and what's
the fun of it otherwise right I mean
what's the fun of it if you're not gonna
deep dive all the time and that also
sort of feeds featherstone like
Featherstone herself would go all the
way a hundred and fifty percent with all
of these personas it just it also
lazin to who Featherstone is like her
sort of her commitment level and how she
goes about life and her focus levels she
would run with it as far as she could
possibly run with it ya know for sure
and I mean I think also we see with
photos somewhere this like endless
possibility third comes in is with the
the Glock she fixes in front of her
start and then I saw your Instagram you
posted a training video that so we're
gonna ask you are you getting out into
like jana reeves training for John wick
mode or like are you gonna be good at
all this and doing your own stunts like
what what is this process I well I do
like to do as much as I can do stunts
wise I hope that we'll see some fight
action from Featherstone Dale I mean
should we three yet but should we get a
season three and we should the show
continue and I actually John koyama our
amazing fight choreographer and I did
like a little training session just so
you could sort of see what I can do I
have like I have a purple belt in
Taekwondo which is like a four it's
definitely like a fourth level belt I
had to stop when we started sparring so
much I kept getting hit in the face and
that's not good when you're an actor so
but I I've been toying with going back
to that since you know since I'm doing
preacher now but I will always do as
much as I can do because that's in
whatever area like there was an option
to shoot the gun bits in that scene as
their own thing like as their own
close-up so that I didn't have to do it
take my take and I was like no way so I
I immediately went to her armor who is a
former NOLA police detective and he is
also an instructor on their dry on their
firing range now and he taught me and I
mean I've worked with Glocks before but
I've never taken one apart and then I
bugged him every day like every single
day I was on whether I was working or
not and I would just you know knock on
the door and I see TJ can I have my gun
and I was just practice and he just let
me I mean I must have driven him nuts
but I wanted AI wanted them I wanted
Michael doubts to be able to shoot the
scene however he wanted to and I just
thought it was cooler be as an actor it
just feels awful to have to have an
expertise as a character and not be able
to
illustrate that I mean it's just not
it's just that disconnect is never sits
well with me and I don't know I also
just like it I mean why wouldn't you why
wouldn't you go for that skill set if
you if the tools are there for you and
they're willing to teach you why
wouldn't you go for that right yeah I
also wanted you know usually if you're
taking apart a gun or cleaning a gun
that's your primary focus and I wanted
the primary focus in the scene to be her
star instead of the gun so I really
wanted it to be second nature so I did
it until I could almost do it without
looking at anything I did it until it
felt like muscle memory
that's amazing like that is props to you
putting that extra effort I like it a
lot it showed for sure and in that scene
I was asked you to with Featherstone why
do you think she has this obsession and
wanting to impress her star so much is
that like that comments like college or
he's kind of ignoring her and it's that
counting Mouse thing where she wants the
attention because she's not getting it
where is that routing from you think no
I think I think it goes a lot further
than that I think to classify
Featherstone as classically in love with
her star is not quite accurate I think
it's more like a cult leader kind of
love and I think she's look Featherstone
is a true believer she's in the Grail
because she's a zealot something has
happened to her in her past that broke
her on the inside and made her capable
of the things she does now I feel like
there's like a black void where her
heart's supposed to be and that's where
Hoover fits into her life right Hoover
still has his heart intact right so
Hoover kind of drives her crazy but she
knows she kind of needs him on a
humanity level but her star is he
represents foshan believes that the
world has gone to hell that darkness has
taken over the world that's why she's
here and if she has to blow up the world
Phillips in order to save it that's what
she will do and that's what she's
willing to do so hair star represents
that level of commitment and that level
of strength to her I mean he just is
total strength and devotion and focus to
her like he is everything she thinks
that the Grail should be he's willing to
do whatever it takes he doesn't he never
questions himself he's he's it
this it's a cult-like thing you know
yeah
Wow I think you totally clear that up
for me and that's nice I'm really
excited too because I I like that's not
as cut-and-dry and it leads that cold
thing and that's so cool for the shows
like the last six stuff it gets deep
gory and there's so much humor and it's
really going for it the show in general
is just not like anything else on TV
which I really appreciate because it's
such a crowded field now but that good
for AMC man I mean every time I see
something that they say oh they'll never
let them do this from the comics and I'm
like yeah we're kind of doing that like
I like so I mean AMC you took a big risk
putting preacher on the air I mean who
does a TV series of preacher if you read
the comics you do not look at that and
think it can exist on television but
then you use to take risk over and over
and over again I mean even just having
what seems to be a sympathetic Hitler on
the show I'm sure they're losing
advertisers over so like they but
they're they're totally committed
they love that the show pushes the
envelope and they are I mean full props
to them for taking that risk absolutely
agreed that and I think that's when II
one doesn't watch the show as watches
never you watch the show to see Julianne
and Emory kick ass
that's Featherstone last question I have
if you I have two more questions first
one I think go for it you don't have the
answers but are we gonna see any new
disguises the Featherstone this season
so that would be a spoiler and I live in
a spoiler free zone so I would never
ever tell you that okay so how about
this do you do you as an actors hope to
see a new disguise come this season or
in the future I will say this it is my
favorite part of Featherstone is the
transformational aspect of her so yes I
hope that that continues absolutely
awesome and my last question is you
actually cop in my Yoda pot before and I
have a capital to how the Cassidy I do
from preacher and I want to know when
are we getting the Featherstone pop what
do we have to talk to to get that well
that is so very much not up to me that
is up to the people at Funko pop and
absolutely die if that I mean that would
just blow my mind way too much that
would just be too over the top I mean
the comic quick world is new for me like
better call Saul the better call Saul
Breaking Bad
fan world is very intelligent very
specific they watch everything they'll
notice something that's out of focus
behind you on a shelf and talk about it
online they're very hardcore so I was
used to like a hardcore intelligent
fandom which preacher definitely is but
the comic book on the dedication to it
really kicks it up a level it was really
I mean before the show while we were
shooting a few people put up on Twitter
I've been waiting 22 years to see
feathers show and brought to life I've
been waiting 17 years to see photo show
brought to life and on one hand that's
so cool and I totally get it because I'm
a giant fan of things myself on the
other hand I'm like okay no pressure
anything I hope they don't hate my
rendition of Featherstone cuz she varies
like the beating heart of her is
straight from the comics but she but we
have taken her further much like they've
taken chulip further we've taken
Featherstone further than the comics
well I'll let you know from the nerd
community we love you we accept you in
your killing as Featherstone nothing to
worry about there take the pressure off
I wish you the best of luck the rest of
the season and if you love Julianne
Murray on preacher you can also catch
her on previous episodes of better call
Saul and Fargo which she's also great on
and uh yeah catch preacher Monday nights
at 9:00 and is there anything else
coming up that we can get excited about
you're doing future projects on the road
do with it yeah I have I have four
movies coming up and they don't yeah
yeah so one of them is a is a Christmas
movie so I assume that'll be out
sometime around November but I'm working
on and my preacher break I'm working on
some some little films so I'm stoked
about that yeah can't wait all right
Julia thank you so much for joining me
everyone please catch preacher is there
any else you want to say Julie before
you head out no watch preacher and if
you are a fan of preacher and you want
to see it renewed we don't have a
renewal for season three yet try to
watch it the week that it airs like you
don't have to watch it then I am a binge
watcher myself but but it you don't have
to watch it the night at airs although
that's nice
but plus 3 and plus 7 counts a lot for
us so if you're a fan of preacher and
you want to see it continue try to watch
it the week that it's up and I know fans
are concerned - does that count do you
know that
like that week we watch it let's say
on-demand right after it airs like does
that go to like anything anything within
seven days so there's like a rating for
watching it that night there's a rating
for watching it within three days and
there's a rating for watching it within
seven so all of that sort of counts and
also social engagement counts now like
talk about it on Twitter that matters in
you know the powers-that-be
weighing in and we have a very good
social engagement with preacher
particularly on Twitter but but yeah if
you want to see the show continue get
involved and try to watch it the week
that it's up excellent everyone you
heard the lady
Julie thank you so much for joining me
and I hope to speak to you soon thank
you so much for having me this is really
nice
awesome